i kind of compare it with being at a
giant
dog park some of them love it like you
start giving them armpit scratches and
they're just like giant dogs they just
start rolling around and they're flying
all around you but these animals are
huge
people are intimidated by them but once
you once you learn their behavior
they're just right into you right away
they just look at you like a big chew
toy
i could never see myself living anywhere
other than the pacific northwest
i could literally spend every single day
the rest of my life and never travel
anywhere other than vancouver island and
i would still never have enough time to
see this whole place
my first introduction to the ocean would
have definitely come from my mom
the sea lion right there later on in
life realize it is a pretty unique
experience to get to out and spend time
with these animals on a regular basis
sea lions are a large
intelligent animal and they're very
sensitive of what your intentions are
and and how they choose to interact with
you is totally their choice
if you're comfortable and and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fans or they come up and
they chew on the edge of your mask or
give you big kisses on the lips or big
hugs they wrap their fins around you and
give you a big hug
people get sketched out about it like
i've had lots of people contact me and
be like don't you think those things are
aggressive just because in animals
putting its mouth on you doesn't mean
it's doing it in a harmful way they
don't have hands they can't explore
their world with anything other than
their mouth
there's people that spend
a lot of money to travel to the other
side of the planet to watch a group of
large migratory animals in africa or
something say and here i can just go out
on my boat and it's not something i take
for granted at all anymore having the
opportunity to do this